hey youtubers is Charlie everybody's
freaking out about Justice League the
Batman movie there's a whole bunch of
rumors going around so wanted to explain
everything it's not as bad as you think
do not freak out hopefully help you
chill out
new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything
I know everybody's freaking out right
now but I'm gonna count down and explain
what's going on where everything is when
that trailer is going to be coming do
not worry so number 10 there were rumors
circulating that the Batman movie is
going to be delayed in Justice League is
a mess now when you actually like
investigate these it's really like
somebody who knew someone who is someone
on the set it's very unverified so you
have to take it with a grain of salt
usually the source for info on this is
really shady so what we do know is that
delaying movies you know however long is
usually a good thing because it means
they have more time to get things right
that was one of the big problems with
Suicide Squad they just didn't have
enough time to get a really good script
and that's really what people have been
talking about for the Batman movie like
is the script done is there a script at
all yes there's a script in one of the
Aquaman screenwriters actually leaked a
bunch of information about the DC movies
including Justice League saying all the
things that you want to hear so this is
actually what his quote was I hope I'm
not going to get in trouble for saying
this but it's much more fun much poppier
saying that it pops much more than
Batman V Superman he says that he hasn't
seen Wonder Woman but he's basically
saying that the somber tone of Batman V
Superman is now sort of like the bottom
of the benchmark everything else is
getting way more hopeful way more fun
so Wonder Woman is going to be a really
fun movie but really once we get to
Justice League that's going to be the
kind of fun summer movie that you would
want to go see even though it's coming
out during November that's the funny
thing it's kind of a summer movie but
it's coming out late in the year he also
talked a little about the Aquaman movie
people are calling it a swashbuckling
adventure which just sounds like a ton
of fun we can talk more about Aquaman in
another movie but respected people are
saying that the movies are doing fine so
I would trust that number 9 Ben Affleck
litter
we just went on jimmy kimmel because of
all the drama last week with people
quoting him saying that he might not
direct justice league that was like the
headline that was going around I made a
funny video about it how Ben Affleck is
just having fun with people just
trolling a little bit he is totally
gonna direct the Batman movie and this
is the quote from Jimmy Kimmel are you
going to directly the next amount of
direct the next Batman we're working on
you because I live by night took me a
year and a half to write it and get it
ready and I work really hard and this
just nobody gave it almost like right
yeah right Oh give me a second so
feeling a little bit better about this
number eight what was all that business
last week about him not doing it that
was mostly him just saying that we're
not gonna start until the script is
ready we don't want to fall into the
same trap again because it's no secret
that a lot of big Hollywood movies not
just comic book movies start shooting
the movie before the script is finished
the other really good example of this is
Star Trek beyond they were actually
writing pages as they were shooting
scenes on Days during that film it is
crazy to think that they would start
making a hundred and fifty million
dollar film without finishing the script
so the more time you have to work on
things the better
number seven though the script
worst-case-scenario the batman script
takes a little bit longer to finish and
they just start shooting later this year
they were originally supposed to start
shooting this summer that means that you
know it takes a couple more months to
finish the script they just start
shooting later in the year meaning that
worst case scenario the film gets bumped
from the middle of 2018 till a little
bit later it's supposed to be summer
2018 they haven't put it on the schedule
yet but that's only because they don't
want to run into Suicide Squad problems
with rushing the film out just all going
into the idea that they won't start till
it's ready once they start shooting it
then they'll announce a release date so
number six when is the movie actually
supposed to come out so originally
Justice League two was scheduled for
2018 that was like way long time ago
that they did that so early on when they
started to retool what was
going on with the DC extended universe
they moved that to 2019 just to give
themselves some extra room in the idea
was is that the Batman movie would move
into that time slot so sometime between
May and July of 2018 originally like I
said if it was delayed it would just
come out later in the year but number
five what do we actually know about the
Batman movie so we actually know a few
things
it's Gotham centric and even though
we're gonna see characters from other
films like you know they've been a lot
of cameos in previous DC films the flash
was in the Suicide Squad movie you'll
see other characters like Harley Quinn
and the Joker but they're not the main
villains of the film it's primarily
being described is an Arkham Prison
Break movie in the tone and style of the
raid redemption which is just this crazy
Indonesian action thriller where you
follow this small tactical squad of
soldiers that have to fight their way up
to the top of a high-rise floor-by-floor
to take down a crime boss but in Arkham
you're fighting your way down to the
bottom the lower you go the more
dangerous the criminals are so you just
have to imagine that all of Batman's
worst villains are locked up in there by
Batman himself and they get released
he's forced to fight his way down to the
bottom so you get to see the best
version of Batman doing all the most fun
things chasing down villains crazy moves
lots of toys and crazy intensity so wait
a minute number four if they already
have the idea why is the script taking
so long to finish Geoff Johns was a
co-writer he's like mr. comic book so
writing the plot is actually the easy
part it's really like the dialogue the
motivation you know what the
interactions between the characters are
going to be that's the hard part to fill
in that's the stuff they're working on
to try and get right like who are these
characters in this movie in how do the
other films inform that so you have to
remember that the new thing at DC is
that this is an extended universe the
movies all have to fit together like
puzzle pieces which makes it that much
harder because it used to be that you
just make a Batman movie even if you're
making a trilogy you don't have to worry
about other people's films it doesn't
matter what Superman is doing Ernie the
other DC characters now people like
Geoff Johns have been
brought on to do the Kevin Feige thing
at DC and just make sure that all the
puzzle pieces fit together which makes
it even harder to write scripts for new
movies so number three what does that
big puzzle look like what is the
overarching story Marvel has their
Infinity Gauntlet storyline that started
with the first Avengers film for DC
that's the cosmic threat of Darkseid in
Apocalypse remember there are three
mother boxes on the earth those will be
very important but so far they've
actually done a good job of telling this
larger story with the other films even
though they didn't have the idea for
justice Lee till after they made Man of
Steel so it all starts with how the
world reacts to an alien with the powers
of a god so that's what the Superman Man
of Steel movie was all about people
learn about him predictably
the entire world freaks out so you have
Batman V Superman in the aging Batman
who's been made cynical and paranoid by
his years of fighting crime so much so
that he's taken the cowl off treats
Superman like a threat if he's a threat
than we have to neutralize him so that's
basically where you are in Batman V
Superman but at the end of that he and
the rest of the world are inspired by
Superman's sacrifice so you get the
Suicide Squad and you meet people like
Amanda Waller the worst human being
imaginable even she respected Superman
she says at least he shared our values
we might not be so lucky with other
aliens so that's where you have Darkseid
apocalypse Steppenwolf the Justice
League movie so Batman has to go around
and recruit these people without the
help of Superman
everybody loves Superman so there'd be
no conflict if he were around that's why
you have to reserve him for like the big
final fight so Batman has to go around
and inspire the other members of the
Justice League that they need to come
together so Justice League you know
within the context of the movie is about
people turning around and coming
together the Justice League movie is
also going to do that for the fandom but
the problem is is that nobody's seen the
trailer we haven't seen the movie yet it
just it isn't here yet so everybody's
still freaking out so number two big
update on Justice League is that they're
still editing it there might be a couple
shoots but they're pretty much done
making the movie and they're just
editing it in post-production adding the
special effects that's what takes the
longest to do all the really small
things so number one that means that
there is a trailer it's sitting on a
shelf somewhere Zack Snyder confirmed
that it was coming very very soon about
a month ago so why haven't we seen it
yet well like I said there was an
election in the US that causes a lot of
economic uncertainty so Studios pull
their spending back they actually
released trailers as part of ad
campaigns that involves them spending a
lot of money so when they stop spending
money it just means fewer trailers so
what they're doing is is they're just
kind of waiting for everyone to chill
out and for a really big event with
guaranteed eyeballs and that is the
Superbowl which is probably where we'll
see that trailer but if you're wondering
why we haven't seen it yet you can just
blame a lot of the economic uncertainty
happening right now in the fact that all
studios have been really pulling back
like even the Logan movie that's getting
ready to come out has not posted a ton
of trailers or footage like people are
just holding off a little bit until
everything chills out so don't worry
it's going to be awesome
if there's anything else that you guys
want me to explain to make you feel
better about stuff just let me know in
the comments there's going to be flash
ring giveaway every week the Marvel
videos that I do have the spider-man
giveaway there's a special Hulkbuster
giveaway that I'm doing for my agents of
shield videos so we all just need to
chill out a little bit it's going to be
awesome new agents of shield will post
in the morning though what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
all my flash predictions for the rest of
the season and you can click here to
learn all about Thor Ragnarok and how
that leads into infinity [ __ ]
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you